GUSTAVO MANTOVAN: Heads up.
LORIN PRICE: Whoa.
Easy there.
Not everyone has time for
these fun beach antics.
I have a network to maintain.
Gotta make sure these
developers play by the rules.
GUSTAVO MANTOVAN: Why are
you worried about that?
Aren't you using Shared VPC?
LORIN PRICE: What's Shared VPC?
GUSTAVO MANTOVAN: Shared
VPC allows an organization
to connect resources
from multiple projects
to a common VPC network so
that they can communicate
with each other securely
and efficiently,
use internal IPs
from that network.
LORIN PRICE: Wow.
But how does that help
me with maintaining
control of my network?
GUSTAVO MANTOVAN:
Shared VPC admins
can delegate network
administration tasks
to network and security admins
in the Shared VPC network.
LORIN PRICE: Now we're talking.
Can you show me
how to set it up?
GUSTAVO MANTOVAN: You bet.
Let's take a look.
To start off, I'm logged
in as Gustavo Mantovan,
with the organizational
administrator for this domain,
bringtothecloud.com.
After I'm logged in,
the organization admin
needs to elect someone
or a group of people
to be the compute
Shared VPC admin
on the organizational
level, who in this case
will be Mary Smith.
Normally, it will be whoever
is responsible for managing
the network in your environment.
We will also give the
project owner permission
to Mary for the Shared
VPC host project.
So she can create new
VPCs and firewalls.
This is not a required
step to set up Shared VPC.
However for this demo
it will make it easier
to demonstrate the
Shared VPC creation.
Once that's done, I'll log
out as Gustavo there on admin,
and I will login as Mary
with the Shared VPC admin
and can set up the Shared VPC.
After I'm logged
in as Mary, I will
go to the
bttc-sharedvpc-hostproject,
which will be the host
project for the Shared VPC.
And for this demo, I
will create a new VPC
called
sharedvpc-bringtothecloud,
with two subnetworks,
one for development
and another for production.
Mary, as the net ops
engineer, does not
want anyone to be using
the default VPC on the host
project.
So she deleted the G4 VPC.
Once that's complete, Mary
creates two firewalls,
one for allowing SSH to
the instance in the new VPC
and another allowing ICMP
between the two subnetworks.
This rule we are
creating just to show
we have connectivity between
different subnetworks
within the Shared VPC.
Now that Mary has everything
set up and ready to go,
she will go ahead and start
creating the Shared VPC.
She goes to the Shared VPC page
and clicks Set Up Shared VPC.
First step is to enable
these projects as the host
projects of the Shared VPC.
Next, you'll have
to select which
subnets you want to
share in the Shared VPC.
You can select all subnets
or select individual.
In this case, Mary selects
the development and production
subnets.
Finally, you have to select
the projects you want
to attach to the Shared VPC.
Those projects are
called service projects,
and they will consume the
networks from the host project.
Mary selects the development
and the production projects.
After doing that, I
will logout as Mary
and login as Charko,
the development owner,
and create an instance
using the Shared VPC subnet.
As you can see, Charko checks
the box Networks Shared With Me
and select the
Development subnet.
After that, he creates
the instance normally.
Now, I will logout as
Charko and login as John
and do the same thing.
However, John will
create an instance
in the production project
for which he is the owner.
When all that is done, I will
pin the development instance
from the production instance
using the Shared VPC
internal IP address to
confirm I have connectivity
and the Shared VPC is working.
There you have it.
Simple and easy.
And Mary has all the
control she needs
to give the appropriate
engineers access
to the right
networking resources.
LORIN PRICE: Life is amazing.
The network administrators
have complete control
over the network
and no longer need
to worry about any
network changes that
were made by the developers.
This lets the developers focus
more on what they're best at
and helps me to
relax a bit more.
If you enjoyed
today's demo, don't
forget to like,
comment, and subscribe.
GUSTAVO MANTOVAN: And if you'd
like to get in contact with us,
click on the link
in the description.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]